ne pas regretter
à côté
à demain
non
je
je n'aime pas
la question
la question tout le monde se pose même
si vous pourquoi le gars comme ça il est
parti s'échauffer va dire quand les
d'aqmi choubaki j'adore mathieu lui
demandait pourquoi tu avais peu de vie
sexuelle regarde aller bien et quand
même à l'époque où la boue que l'on
donne qui s'abandonne téléphone c'est
pas moi avons pardon est un téléphone
qui sonne
non c'est moi numéro masqué à loket un
appareil ils ont raccroché nrj 12 sur la
même personne c'est qui joli numéro à ce
qui c'est qui c'est bien toi mais va le
dire t'inquiète pas marcolino jour même
m
je réponds non iron allô allô c'est
mathieu répondait arrêté de me
persécuter qui est à l'appareil dit vite
dites moi dit toujours les bons skis aux
pieds là j'ai pas qu'ils aient pas à mon
avis c'est aux banques et non à sa
numéro de risque oui c'est tout bon ok
je sais pas qui c'est mais faut arrêter
avec ce téléphone mafieuse j'ai déjà dit
par téléphone
ici même